13h08
l'heure est venue de nous entretenir
avec notre invité le nouveau président
de la communauté d'agglomération du
centre de la martinique la cacem luc
louison clementé bonjour bonjour vous
voici donc maintenant président d'epic
c'est un échelon supplémentaire dans
votre parcours politique
alors est ce que c'est un mandat que
vous souhaitiez personnellement ou
finalement ne vous et shoot il nous est
soit il que parce que le tour de
présidence de la cacem revient
maintenant là en 2020 la ville de
schoelcher et que comme vous êtes le
maire de cette ville et bien vous ne
pouvez faire autrement c'est tellement
d'exaltant exaltant à divers titres
pourquoi parce que vous le souhaitiez
vous le vous livre mais bien sûr bien
sûr exaltant parce que on se retrouve un
poste de commande où nous avons une
vision beaucoup plus large que c'est une
seule commune de ce point de vue j'avoue
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à faire et
pour notre part nous sommes complètement
déterminé à tout mettre en oeuvre pour
cela
alors si vous voulez globalement
beaucoup de choses seront à faire on va
revenir pour l'instant on va y revenir
très bien vous avancez vous avez des
priorités des projets c'était juste pour
avoir votre votre détermination
personnelle à occuper ce sont des
questions on est prêt voilà alors
précisément le clémente et comment allez
vous vous organiser car il ya du travail
en perspective vous venez de différents
illusion mais il ya aussi du pain sur la
planche à la municipalité celle 3
ça demande du temps alors certains au
sein des élus et de la population presse
même que ce ne soit pas forcément
systématiquement un maire qui soit
président de communauté d'agglo surtout
quand celui ci est à la tête d'une
grosse ville à notre échelle
donc voilà compte tenu de l'ampleur des
tâches
alors comment comment vous allez vous
organiser pour concilier les deux ce
n'est pas un homme comme à la tête d'une
commune c'est une équipe c'est important
et j'ai la chance dans mon équipe à
notre équipe d'avoir les personnes sûr
que je peux vraiment content et il ce
point de vue après de mandature passée à
la tête la ville de schoelcher nous
avons acquis les réflexes nécessaires
nous permettant de savoir là où il est
important d'agir et bien entendu rien eu
si jamais fâché le cher le pôle travaux
responsabilités sans un plan vraiment
très strictement élaboré et respectez
donc de ce point de vue c'est avec
beaucoup d'inquiétude que j'envisage
l'avenir de ce point de vue à la casse m
il s'agira pour nous d'en faire autant
et d'organiser notre temps de telle
sorte que nous puissions à chaque fois
trouver les voies et moyens nous
permettant d'être le plus efficace
possible
alors contenu je disais compte tenu de
l'ampleur de la tâche et la cacem comme
toutes les autres communautés d'agglo de
france 1 hexagonal et de ses divers
tirés territoire la cacem va devoir être
en ces temps de d'épidémie de postes
épidémique à la fois pompière pour
éteindre l'incendié de la crise
économique et sociale posco vide puis
infirmières aussi un petit peu la casse
m pour contribuer à soigner les
administrés et puis les entreprises de
sa zone qui est faut-il le rappeler le
poumon économique de notre île
donc tout à fait beaucoup de boulot là
qui s'annonce sera fait en tout cas on
va en tenir pour l'instant trois grandes
directions dans lesquelles le scrutin
comment dire allez aujourd'hui la
première consiste en question en raison
il ya une éducation la commission des
finances a déjà été constituée d arras
maison théâtre justement très rapidement
notre de marché le sac il s'agit pour
qu'on puisse sauter nos budgets est
véritablement déclaré ouvert justement
les chantiers on va dire ça comme ça
peut aller vite donc trois directions
10e la première consiste à booster au
maximum l'économie du centre de la
martinique
la seconde trouver les voies et moyens
permettant d'avoir un maximum
d'autonomie en eau parce que nous avons
connu une crise tout récemment faut pas
que ça se reproduise je vous souhaite
véritablement que du 1er janvier au 31
décembre de chaque année tous les
robinets des administrés usagers de la
cacem territoire communautaire puisse
couler sans aucune difficulté
et bien la fin de la transition
énergétique sera au rendez vous de nos
de nos priorités et la troisième le
troisième élément qui me paraît
essentiel également c'est la
participation citoyenne
l'intergénération lorsqu'ils sont du
premier point nous allons aux premiers
temps pour booster l'économie nous
attaquer au projet de territoire de la
cacem qui sera revue parce que comme
comme vous comme comme nous on se
réalise que finalement le poste qu vide
n'est pas neutre le coc vide a révélé
donc il va falloir une phase assez
exactement c'est tout à fait ça doit
faire preuve d' imaginaires exactement
pour apporter une des solutions les plus
pertinentes
la relation dont elle se pose sur le
terrain et pour ça nous reverrons de
projet de territoire
deuxième élément de cette de cette façon
de booster l'économie consistera à
renforcer le plan de relance post coït
qu'ils ont mis en place à titre
d'exemple ils ont mis en place un
système au niveau duquel nous prenons en
charge un certain nombre de mois de
loyer pour les petits les petites
entreprises mais aussi celles qui
relèvent de la production locale et sur
la taxe comment dire de séjour que nous
percevons là aussi les efforts ont été
faits troisième point qui n'est pas
neutre non plus si l'année si c'est
qu'il ya de lutter contre la
dévitalisation de nos centres bourgs il
ya urgence aujourd'hui de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour qu'on puisse comprendre que
un beau ce seul vote est véritablement
un lieu de vie pas quelque part où on
vient acheter et repartir mais quelque
part on dort quelque part on se déplace
quelque part on prend les transports
publics
quelque part on se distrait on se
divertit ses symboles et on fera tout
pour que les choses aillent dans ce sens
et puis enfin que serait tout ce que je
viens de dire si on avait pas territoire
propre il faut absolument tout mettre en
oeuvre pour que le territoire de la
cacem soin de tes les trois exemples et
un nouveau lieu de la provôté ça c'était
pour le premier point booster l'économie
le deuxième point l'année c'est la
nécessaire transition écologique qu'il
faut assurer chaque jour qui passe nous
prouve combien nous sommes très loin des
objectifs qu'on pourrait se fixer car il
y va véritablement de la préservation de
la planète
il est urgent que nous trouvions les
voies et moyens nous permettant
d'atteindre au moins 40% à l'horizon
2030 d'une baisse de du tout pétrole ça
il faut mettre un terme à ça et là je
suis personnellement déterminé pour cela
et je me parlait de l'eau est également
tout à l'heure l'auscitain c'est un vrai
sujet aux rites et des priorités c'est
une priorité d'un vrai sujet
oui oui alors comment comptez vous vous
y prendre pour les premières actions à
mettre en oeuvre de ce point de vue par
rapport à la distribution d'eau parce
que vous devez alors la cacem on a la
compétence comme bien sûr toutes les
communautés d'agglomération mais vous
devez néanmoins composer avec des bombes
bien sûr les mairies qui font partie de
la cacem tout ça mais des mastodontes
aussi des opérateurs des fermi enfin qui
sont à la fois publiques et privées
enfin bon voilà et puis et puis vous
fait vous il faut faire aussi avec
l'aval de l'état qu'il ya des acteurs
aussi alors voilà tout ça alors de ce
point de vue je suis assez serein
nous avons toujours eu comme méthode au
lieu d'autres groupes politiques de
privilégier tout les forcelais possible
la constatation savoure le sens pour moi
donc très tôt dès le lendemain des
élections dans les deux autres opci cap
nord et espace sud
je proposerai à mes collègues la cacem
une rencontre avec les deux autres
officie pour que nous puissions ensemble
avec le maximum d'efficacité déterminer
les voies et moyens permettant de régler
son volume de l'eau et sans dévoiler
comment dire un secret j'ai reçu tout
récemment un sms de monsieur le préfet
existants pour une velits citant pour
cette élection en me précisant qu'il
était prêt à nous aider autant qu'ils le
pourraient ce problème de l'eau non
voilà les services de l'état sont prêts
nous sommes preneurs depuis 6 ou la
colle à la la la la compétence incombe
donc il n'y a pas de raison lorsqu'une
voulons pas c'est aussi un chemin voilà
il faut il faut prendre le chemin il
faut passer aux actes
- aux paroles et plus d'actes espèce
d'accord pour le pour lui c'est très
bien dernière question le clémente et
vous parliez de l'environnement de souci
écologique et cetera
la cacem un produit il ya quelques temps
un communiqué indiquant qu'elle qu'elle
était un peu outré de voir gants masques
mouchoir à usage unique et cetera
traîner ici ou là alors tout à l'heure
moi j'ai vu se trouvait un masque en
arrivant dans le studio alors peut-être
que c'est quelqu'un qui l'a oublié puis
ça s'est retrouvé par terre mais enfin
voila j'ai dû le mettre à la poubelle
dans cette période il est important
peut-être justement dans votre parole
publique de vous adresser aux habitants
des quatre communes qui composent a
cassé mais hélas dessus de faire
vraiment un effort quand je serai simple
je serai clair une chose est certaine
c'est que quelle que soit l'importance
des fonds que nous mettrons à
disposition vous les volumes de propreté
si à la base y'a pas une prise de
conscience forte de la population n'y
arrivera pas une prise de conscience il
faut passer oui alors le communiqué
alors c'était pas sous votre présidence
mais est ce que vous serez un peu dans
le même état d'esprit il ya la
prévention puis il est indiqué que tout
contrevenant se verra appliquer les
sanctions en vigueur
quel sens pavone politique de prévention
si derrière n'ya pas les pour les
distinctions possible au roi jeudi parce
que
dago j est essentiel d'un se lance donc
dans ce domaine là il faudra commencer
par les plus petits vous qu'il puisse
nous aider à enseigner aux plus grands
comment faire ça c'est une première que
souvent ça marche comme ça voilà
deuxième chose et je le dis avec fois il
ya une grande majorité de gens qui
respectent les choses on a une minorité
de malpropres qu'il faut stigmatiser
verbaliser et faire comprendre que la
martinique ce n'est pas par accouchement
au contraire que nous sommes prêts
aujourd'hui c'est votre parent de
président de la cacem jeunes de mettre
en oeuvre à tout mettre en oeuvre pour
avoir territoire propre c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit on ne peut pas vouloir non
plus avoir des ambitions en matière de
promotion touristique le développement
de l'auto rythme sans un territoire prof
ça n'a pas de sens donc là dessus la
cacem donnera toute sa part et prendra
toute sa part dans ce dans ce défi de la
martinique
les notes électro merci le que louison
clémente et maire de schoelcher et
président de la cacem donc pour six ans
maintenant
voilà merci d'être venu d'avoir répondu
à nos questions